[موسيقى]
انا خليفه
المسلمين وانا
امامهم وانا المسؤول عن
[موسيقى]
حمايتهم لا عاش ابن هارون
الرشيد ان لم يثار للاطفال والشيوخ
والنساء لعش
المعتصم ان لم تجد
المسلمات من يحمي
اعرضهم لقد اخبرني هذا الرجل يا مولاي
امرا يجب ان
تسمع قل اني اسمعك يا مولاي لقد عذب الروم
امراه اسمها شرات
العلويه قوها سبيا ونكلوا بها وقد صرخت
باعلى صوتها و
[موسيقى]
معتصمه و
معتصمه و معتصمه لبيك يا اخته لبيك يا
اختى لبيك يا
[موسيقى]
اخت عندما دخل ملك الروم تيوفيل حصن زبطره
في جنوب غرب تركيا وقتل نخبه اهلها
واستعبد الباقي واخذ في الاسر الف امراه
مسلمه حتى استغاثت احداهن في سوق مدينه
عموريه ونادت و معتصماه اجابها الخليفه
المعتصم لما بلغه الخبر لبيك يا اختاه
لبيك يا اختاه وشرع بتجهيز جيش عظيم فيه
اكثر من 200 الف مقاتل وقاده لتحرير الارض
واطلاق الاسيرات وهزي
المحتل في اثناء تجهيزه للحرب حذره احد
مستشاريه مولاي المعتصم انك ستسير ب 200
الف جندي سيستشهد منهم من يقضي ويسر من
يؤسر كما سيقتل جيش الرومي البالغ القوه
ويعتقل عشرات الالاف منا فهل من الحكمه ان
نذهب الى معركه تكون فيها خسائرنا اكثر من
ارباحنا نظر اليه المعتصم بازدراء وقال له
ايها المستشار الخوار الهلوع لو ان لديك
عشره من الابناء وبنتا واحده اختطفها قطاع
طريق يسترقون
ويغتصبونها هل سترسل ابناءك العشر
لتحريرها حتى لو كانوا سيقتلون ام ستترك
ابنتك خلف السدود وبين ايدي الشياطين ان
كنت تتخلف عن صون عرضك فانا لا اتخلف
وكل بنات المسلمين عرضي
وشرفي صمت المستشار اليه فوف الذي ابتدع
قصته من خيالنا بعدما اوحى لنا فيها بعض
كتاب الخنوع والتثبيط الذين يقدمون انفسهم
للعالم وكانهم مستعدون لرش اي محتل قادم
الى بلادهم بالورد والياسمين عندما يسقط
عواصم ويحتل مقدساتهم وي يقتل شعوبهم
ويخطف بناتهم فالعيش
والعيش اسماء
امانيهم الى
العناوين صحيفه ريتس حماس باقيه ولن تذهب
الى اي
مكان جنرال اسرائيلي كبير كتائب القسام
قويه ومستعده لقتال
طويل بعد فشل ثلاثيته الخشبيه نتنياهو
يرضخ للهدنه وتبادل
الاسرى تحيات ورسائل وداع وديه تتركها
الاسيرات المفرج عنهن
للمقاومه جيش الاحتلال يسرق حلوى تحرير
الاسيرات في الضفه
الغربيه شهادات مروعه عن ظروف اعتقال
النساء والاطفال في اسرائيل
يعيشون في بيوتهم المدمره ويصلون على
انقاض
المساجد فضيحه كبرى ومسرحيه هزليه لجيش
الاحتلال على فوكس
نيوز اطفال العرب يريدون ان يكونوا ابو
عبيده عندما
[موسيقى]
يكبرون مرحبا بين فواصل الهدن والتهدئه
التي سبقت سؤال الجميع من انتصر فلسطين ام
الاسرائيليون الجواب يبدو سهلا اذا كان
المعيار حجم الضحايا المدنيين والدمار
والتهجير فغزا لم تنتصر لان اسرائيل تقتل
المدنيين فيها بوتيره تاريخيه غير مسبوقه
في الصراعات المسلحه بحسب تحقيق لصحيفه
نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه لكن الجواب يبدو
اكثر سول ايضا اذا كان المعيار عدد القتلى
العسكريين ومدى تحقيق اهداف الحرب بالقضاء
على حماس والمقاومه واستعاده الاسر بالقوه
فاسرائيل هزمت شر هزيمه بحسب اصوات عسكريه
اسرائيليه واعلاميه وازنه صحيفه هرتس تقول
توقف عن الحديث عن مرحله ما بعد حماس
فحماس باقيه ولن تذهب الى اي مكان اذا
المعادله هي التاليه تستطيع قوات الاحتلال
ان تقتل الاطفال والنساء من الجو ليقتلها
الرجال اذا اقتربت من الارض وهذا ما يفسر
فرار الفي جندي اسرائيلي الى جهات مجهوله
غضب داخل الجيش الاسرائيلي طرد ضابطين قاد
كتيبه القتاليه ونائبه اثر انسحاب عناصرها
وتراجعهم خلال المعارك البريه شمال قطاع
غزه ومنذ تلك الاقاله وكنوع من الاحتجاج
نحو نصف مقاتل السريه لم يعودوا الى
الوحده بعض الاطاحه بالضابط تلك الازمه
ليست الاولى من نوعها التي يواجهها الجيش
الاسرائيلي فنحو ال000 جندي اسرائيلي فروا
من الخدمه العسكريه منذ دلاع المعارك في
السابع من اكتوبر ليس العسكريون فقط بل ان
اكثر من 230 الف اسرائيلي غادروا اسرائيل
منذ بدء عمليه طوفان الاقصى فيما
فلسطينيون مغتربون تركوا دول اقامتهم
السبع نجوم على عجل للقاء الاحبه في غزه
او الاستشهاد معهم الغريب كمان ومن ضمن
الاحداث اللي حصلت في اول يوم من الهدنه
ان الاشخاص الفلسطينيين لكن الغير مقيمين
في فلسطين اول ما حسوا ان هم يقدروا
يرجعوا بلدهم طالبوا بدخولهم لفلسطين برغم
ان هم مقيمين اصلا في دول ثانيه وعايشين
في اماكن امنه لكن برغم كده عايزين يرجعوا
بلدهم اللي راجعين من على الحدود من مصر
عايز يرجع غزه يا ابني ده انت قاعد هنا في
الامان لا انا راجع انا عايز ارجع
النهارده طب راجع ليه لا انا راجع بلدي
ايه الفلسطينيين دول طبعا عدوا وطبعا
عبروا وطبعا رجعوا ديازي جدعون ناشط
اسرائيلي ينبه الاسرائيليين الى ان جيشهم
يخفي الحقائق عنهم ويقول ان مجموعه
مقاتلين ينتعلون الصنا نادل الشبشب قتلوا
3000 جندي اسرائيلي وليس ما تسمعونه من
الاعلام ويراهن الجميع على ان اسرائيل
ستخسر قريبا اراض امام
الفلسطينيين ديازي جدعون ربما يبالغ في
تصوير انهزاميه جيشهم دعونا منه لكن قاده
المعارك الميدانيه كان يلطمون امام شاشات
غرف عمليات جيش الاحتلال التي سجل مقطع
واحد من رصدها مقتل 36 جنديا في هجوم واحد
فحولت كتائب القسام دبابات النمر الى
اشلاء قطط هذا الكلام لم يقله اسامه حمدان
من بيروت بل ضابط اسرائيلي رفيع ومتدين من
تل ابيب قاله لاستاذه الديني الحاخ
ز
ر
36 لم يعد القلق الاسرائيلي مقتصرا من صوب
غزه فقط فهذا جنرال سابق يعرب عن تخوف
داخل تلبيب من سيطره حماس على الضفه
الغربيه
بالنسبه للاسرائيليين ليس سهلا ان يروا
علم منظمه التحرير مع عالم
حماس يرفعان لان حماس ليست معنيه
بدفع عمليه السلام وحماس طبعا ضد
اوسلو هذا مقلك جدا ليس فقط المواطن
الاسرائيلي وانما ايضا اجهزات الامن
الاسرائيليه لا يريدون الحماس ان تسيطر
على الضفه الغربيه
المطبع الفرحان الجالس على سفينه تغرق ولا
يدري سيجعله هذا الخبر ينام دون عشاء رئيس
مجلس الامن القومي الاسرائيلي السابق يقول
كتائب القسام صامده وقويه بما يكفي لتخوض
قتالا طويل الامد ضدنا انظروا الى اي وضع
متناقض وصلنا كنا نصلي لكي يكون الا
السنوار سيطره جيده على ما يحدث من اجل
تنفيذ صفقه التبا
وهذا يبدو تناق هائلا براي المنظومه
المعاديه صامده وتشعر انها قويه بما يكفي
لتخوض نضالا طويلا ومستمرا ضدنا بعد ذا
كله يكرر نتنياهو ثلاثيته الخشبيه القضاء
على حماس واستعاده الاسرى بالقوه وانهاء
المقاومه الفلسطينيه واي تهديد يرددها هذه
المره ببزه مضاده للرصاص مع جنود
بلس يدلعون نتنياهو في اسرائيل فيقولون له
بيبي او بيبي هل يعتقد بيبي نتنياهو انه
بجوله عدوان جديده يمكنه ان يعثر على
الاسرى فقد اقر نتنياهو في مقابله
تلفزيونيه بانهم كانوا يمتلكون مؤشرات
استخباريه حول وجود اسره بالمستشفى لكن
القوات لم تعثر على اي منهم بعد الاقتحام
اذا خلع نتنياهو نعليه ووقف تحت ضغط
عائلات اسراه ينتظر افراج المقاومه عن بعض
المدنيين منهم بموجب هدن وقف اطلاق النار
وتبادل الاسرى التي سبقت وبرعاية
وقف اطلاق النار وهذا ما لا يراه جبر
الفرحان كتائب القسام نجحت في فرض وقف
اطلاق النار في الشمال والجنوب ايضا تلك
المجموعات العسكريه التي كانت ظاهريا
منقطعه عن الاتصال توقفت عن القتال في
الوقت المحدد وتحرير الاسرى يدار بضبط
وسيطره تماما مثل عمليه عسكريه مستشار
الامن القومي السابق في البيت الابيض جون
بولتون يقول ان حماس اكثر افاده من الهدنه
وقد نجحت في اضعاف الروح المعنويه لجيش
اسرائيل in a military s hamas is the
beneficiary more than the israel side
but hamas that need the break and longer
they can
break better
they effort can help break the mor can
help break the resolve of the israel
forces what they want to do and this is
the real
كيف استطاعت حماس ان تضبط عمليه الاسر
والمحافظه على الاسرى انها وحده الظل في
كتائب القسام او فريق الجحيم في التعريف
الاسرائيلي بحسب هذا التقرير هذان الشابان
العملاقان الضمان الملثم جالت صورتهما كل
العالم فاحما من مدت يدها اليه محتجزه
اسرائيليه مسنه لحظه اطلاق سراحها انهما
من وحده الظل الفلسطينيه في غزه حتى بات
اسمها في اسرائيل وحده ظل الجحيم وبعد ان
بات معلوما ان المهمه الرئيسيه للوحده
تامين ورعايه الاسرى الاسرائيليين في غزه
وابقائه في مكان سري لضمان نجاح عمليات
تبادل الاسرى واذا ما نظرنا الى التعريف
الاسرائيلي لوحده الظل الفلسطينيه فانها
سلاح غزه لاطلاق الاسرى الفلسطينيين من
سجون اسرائيل اما اذا ما استمعنا الى وصف
الفصائل الفلسطينيه في غزه لهم فانهم
ابطال يعملون خلف ستار العتمه وبين الناس
يعيشون حياتهم الطبيعيه فلا تشعروا بانهم
يخفون او يحفظون سرا خلفهم وهم من الحقوا
الهزائم تواليا باجهزه الامن الاسرائيليه
بمختلف مسمياتها مشهد الاسرى
الاسرائيليين وهم يودعون اسريه من رجال
القص سا اثارت جدلا انسانيا كبيرا فمتى
يمكن ان يحب السجين سجانه وخصوصا في وضع
الاسر جانب من الاجابه يؤكد ان المعامله
الحسنه التي قدمتها كتائب المقاومه
الاسلاميه للاسرى فككت حاله الدعر الرهيب
التي كانت تسيطر عليهم ساعه الاسر ومنحتهم
اطمئنانا نسبيا وشيئا من الثقه
الاخلاقيه تكون اغلى ما يحتاجه المرء في
مثل هذه
الحالات
اوكي كلمات الوداع تلك بين احد عناصر حماس
والفتاه الاسرائيليه مايا رغيف والتي كانت
مصحوبه بنظرات يغلب عليها الود والالفه لم
تكن محبذ من قبل شريحه واسعه من
الاسرائيليين الذين عبروا عن سخطهم منها
عبر منشورات متداوله عبر وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي مؤكدين انها اساءت لبلدها ولمعت
صوره مقاتلي حماس امام المجتمع الدولي
باظهار حسن معامله الاسرى على حد قولهم في
الوقت الذي ظهرت فيه للعيان مشاهد التعامل
الودي لعناصر القسام مع رغيف وغيرها من
المحتجزين الذين بدوا مبتسمين وبمعني
مرتفعه عند اطلاق سراحهم التحيه والاشاره
بالوداع بين رغيف وعنصر حماس لم تكن اول
المشاهد التي يتم تداولها وسط الحديث عن
حسن تعامل القسام مع الاسرى الاسرائيليين
فتلو باليدين والابتسامات غير المصطنعه
والتصرفات التي غابت عنها اي مظاهر خوف
وارباك طغت ايضا في موقف اخر عندما تم
تسليم الاسيره الاسرائيليه المسنه يوخ باد
ليف شيتس التي اثارت غضب مكتب نتنياهو
وفئه كبيره في اسرائيل ليس بسبب مصافحتها
عناصر حماس قبل رحيلها فحسب بل تصريحاتها
التي ادلت بها عقب افراج حماس عنها لدوافع
انسانيه الروايه الاسرائيليه تروج مرارا
وتكرارا الى ان حركه حماس تتعمد احتجاز
الرهائن بظروف مزريه وتعتدي عليهم لكن هذه
الروايه اهتزت الثقه بها من خلال المضمون
الذي نشرته كتائب القسام لعمليه اطلاق
سراح الرهائن ضمن اتفاق الهدنه القصيره
بين اسرائيل وحماس لاحظوا ان الفلسطينيين
الذين عاملوا اطفال ونساء الاسرى بهذا
الود اطفالهم ونسائهم مزقتها مقاتلات
اسرائيل في غزه بعض الاعلام العبري كان
منصفا في نقل مشهد الرحمه في التعامل مع
الاسرى من قبل المقاومه الاسلاميه في
فلسطين
بخل
يتسرب من تصريحات الاسيرات الاسرائيليات
المفرج عنه يخترق جدار منع سميك فرضت
حكومه المتخبط نتنيا في غزه هنا اسيره
اسرائيليه تلوح بيدها لعناصر القسام تلقي
السلام على المقاتلين في مشهد عفوي يحمل
من الرسائل ما
يحمل تقول امي انها عملت معامله حسنه وان
الاشخاص هناك كانوا طيبين معها هذه المره
حرصت اسرائيل على تجنب الفضيحه منعت اسراه
الادلاء باي تصريح اعلامي قد يفسد دعايته
امراه اسرائيليه مفرج عنها مع طفلتها في
غزه ودعت كتائب القسام برساله شكر غير
عاديه قالت سابقى ممتنه لكم طيله العمر
لانكم عاملت طفلتي بمحبه حمتها من اي صدمه
نفسيه كان يمكن ان تصاحبها الى الابد
استهلت هذه السيده رسالتها للقسام بالقول
يبدو اننا سنفترق غدا وبتوجيه الشكر من
اعمال قلبها بحسب نص الرساله لمن سمتهم
الجنرالات الذين رافقوها خلال الاسابيع
الماضيه على انسانيتهم التي اظهرو تجاه
ابنتها واكدت ان جميع من قابلتهم حتى
القيادات تصرفوا تجاه ابنتها برفق وحنان
وكانوا لها بمثابه الابوين وخاطبتهم
بالقول ان ابنتها لا تعتبر مجرد اصدقاء
وانما احباء واكدت السيده في رسالتها
لعناصر القسام انها ستبقى شاكره لهم للابد
لان ابنتها لن تخرج مصابه بصدمه نفسيه
وعلى تصرفهم الطيب رغم الوضع الصعب
والخسائر التي اصابت غزه في المقابل وفي
الضفه الغربيه المحتله كان المشهد مختلفا
تماما اقتحم جنود اسرائيليون منزل الاسيره
الفلسطينيه امان حشيم في الضفه قبيل
الافراج عنها وصادروا الحلوى التي اشترتها
اسرتها لتقديمها للمهنئين لا غرابه فقد
سرقوا قبل اسابيع بيوت الاسرائيليين
انفسهم في مستوطنات غلاف غزه ونهبوا
مقتنيات بسييطه وثمينه من الاحذيه الى
المجوهرات
والاموال بكل الاحوال الاسيرات كنا واثقات
من وعد الحريه الذي اطلقه رجال المقاومه
لكن لا مكان للفرح الان وغزه تحت العدوان
تقول الاسيره المحرره اسراء زعا بيس جدا
نخجل ان نفرح وفلسطين كلها جريحه اوجاعي
مرئيه ما في داعي اني احكي عنها غير
اوجاعي من ناحيه المشاعر الاحاسيس الشوق
لهل بس ها هي ضريبه السجن للسجين سجنه
وضريبه المحبه الشوق والحنين
انه بنات صغار بغرفه تركتهم وهم عم بيبكوا
ليش لانه تعرض لاشياء كثيره بالسجن بنات
صغار انا بحكي عن بنات
كبار غ في سجون اسرائيل يوجد اكثر من
2 طفل فلسطيني معتقل بدون تهم رسميه
ومحاكمات
قانونيه يؤكد رئيس المبادره الفلسطينيه
مصطفى البرغوثي لكن ايدي كوهين يسال هل
الاسلام يجيز خطف هؤلاء الاولاد
والنساء جنود ياسر الخوف وصغير مقاوم
رجمهم بحجر يدرك وديع الطفل الفلسطيني ابن
الخمس سنوات ان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
يستحيل ان يكون وديعا ويعلم انه ليس
الوحيد الذي اقتلع من حضن امه الدافئ الى
زنازين معتق
بار يقبع اليوم خلف قضبانها
نحو طفلا
اسيرا يعود الاطفال من مدارسهم الى
منازلهم لكن في فلسطين قد يقطع المحتل
عليهم الطريق ليملا الخوف في حقائب
اعمارهم ويلطخ صفحات ايامهم
بانتهاكات ضاربا القوانين الدوليه
والاتفاقيات بعرض حائط احد الفتيان
المحررين وقد دخل المعتقل طفلا تحدث عن
جوع اطفال فلسطينيين معتقلين دون سن
الثانيه عشر داخل سجون اسرائيل كانوا
جوعونا ما كانوش كانوا جابونا يعني يا دوب
ربطتين لكل لكل غرفه يعني ما تكفينا يعني
شباب في اولاد صغار يعني 12 و 11 سنه يعني
بيعرفو شكل من مره يعني على
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الفاضي
محمد اكبر الله اكبر كل الاحترام لاخوتنا
المجاهدين حما الله يحييكم والله يفرجها
على الجميع وتح كبين الكصار تحي
[موسيقى]
حمام عمليات جيش الاحتلال في غزه تستطيع
قتل الاف الاطفال وال ساء الفلسطينيين
لكنها لم تستطع تحرير قميص اسير اسرائيلي
واحد وسيبقى الفلسطينيون في ارضهم يعيشون
في بيوتهم المدمره ويصلون على انقاض
المساجد يدرك الاحتلال في كل مره انه عبثا
يحاول النيل من الفلسطينيين متناسيا انه
امام شعب ما زادته الايام الا صلابه
واصرار على الحياه وتمسكا بارض ل فلسطين
كلها التي يقول الفلسطينيون انهم معيد
حقوقهم مهما تطاول الزمن وتعاظمت
التضحيات اليوم نصلي في مسجد المصطفى كبار
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين يقولون ان
المقاومه لم تكسر بل كسرت معنويات جيشهم
اما همزه عين ابراهيم عيسى
وبفائدة ينعي كتائب القسام ويطلب لها
الرحمه ويقول ان
جنودها الفر من المعركه يا جماعه غزه
محتله والعمليه الاسرائيليه دخلت في
المرحله الثانيه وبداوا يتغول في وسط
غزه يا جماعه الحمساويه اللي هربوا من
شمال غزه نزلوا على الوسط فهم نازلين
وراهم وينزلوا الى جنوب غزه والمصيبه
بتزداد لا مش مهم المقاومه صامده المقاومه
ناجحه المقاوم يعني خلاص بقى تعمل ايه في
الحاله دي تعمل
ايه تطلب لهم الرحمه على فكره وتشفق عليهم
جدا اخفاق الجيش الاسرائيلي وصل الى مسرح
التمثيل وتحديدا في اخراج مقطع درامي فاشل
يقوم على اعتقال الاسرائيليين احد
المقاومين الفلسطينيين وتعريته لتفتيشه
ليظهر نفس الشخص المعر في اخر الفيديو وهو
يعود ليرتدي ملا
بكل اريحيه وهدوء مراسل قناه فوكس
الاخباريه الامريكيه قام بالتواطؤ مع
افراد الجيش الاسرائيلي لاخراج مسرحيه
كاذبه في الفيديو بيظهر المراسل بيصور
جنود اسرائيليين بيقوموا باعتقال راجل
قالوا انه مقاتل من حماس وتم تجريده من
ملابسه وقبل ما يتوقف التصوير تم ملاحظه
نفس الشخص وهو بيقوم بكامل ارادته ويلبس
ثيابه مره ثانيه من جديد بعد انتهاء
في معركه الراي العام العالم ينقلب ضد
اسرائيل فبعد اسبوع واحد فقط على انطلاق
طوفان الاقصى سجل ان اسرائيل باتت تلعب
على المسرح الدولي ب 5% فقط من تاييد شعوب
العالم وذلك بحسب مركز ابحاث اسرائيلي
اطاح بحظ
نتنياهو
coun i you know israel think tank
today has been
tracking protest around the
world gave some figures for what it
looked like between october 7th and
october 13th since october 13th if you
look at the number of protests around
world
95es and
5ra المكاسب التي حققتها المقاومه بحسب
رصد الباحثين اعاده رفع القضيه الفلسطينيه
على اعلى سلم اولويات الامتين الاسلاميه
والعربيه في تركيا هكذا كانت التحيه
لكتائب القسام وقائدها محمد
الضيف ا
تكب
تكبير
تكبير الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الاسرائيليون تجمعوا من اخر الدنيا
واتوا الى بيت الحاج ابو صبري ودمروه
للمره الرابعه على التوالي لكن ابو صبري
لن يرحل بيت مكون من ثلاث
طواب هي منزلينه كلياته لا في مقاومين ولا
في اي ح و برغم الضمان برغم الضمان
هذاب والشهدا عننا معنوياتنا الحمد لله رب
العالمين معنوياتنا عاليه جدا لكن احنا
الحمد لله بارك الله في المقاومه تبعتنا
اللي رفعت رؤسنا واحنا شامخين برغم هذا
الحصار وهذا الضمار لكن معنوياتنا عاليه
جدا باذن الله تعالى ولا يهمنا لكل
العدوان هذا الاسرائيلي ولا يهز فينا شعب
هؤلاء الذين يتفنون قلوبهم مع فلذات
اكبادهم
ما هي القوه التي تمنحهم الصبر والقرار
بالتحدي وعدم الاستسلام سلمي لي على مين
على حبيب
الامه حبيبنا محمد صلوا عليه اللهم صل على
سيدنا
محمد قول له بحبك كثير بحبك انت والله
اعلم بحبك
اكثر من نفسه ومنك ومن كل الدنيا بحب الله
ورسوله الدوحه اصبحت جناف جديده لحل
للنزاعات في العالم بحسب تقرير لفرانس 24
وتواجد قطر يظهر جليا على الارض يوم السبت
وزيره قطريه مسؤوله عن الجانب الانساني
زارت غزه وتحديدا المعبر الحدودي حيث تمر
الشاحنات المساعدات كما تلقى امير قطر في
نفس اليوم اتصالا هاتفيا من الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن لدفع المفاوضات قدما
وهو الوحيد الذي يحاور اسرائيل وفي نفس
الوقت حماس كما تلعب الدوحه دورا حاس الى
جانب مصر في اطلاق سراح الرهائن اماره
غنيه اصبحت نموذجا يحتذى
بها تريد قطر ان تقدم نفسها بطريقه ما على
انها جناف جديده والدور الذي تريد ان
تعطيه لنفسها هو الطرف المسهل الذي يستطيع
ان يتحدث مع جميع الاطراف ما يضع قطر في
وضع لا يستطيع ان يوازيها احد وزيره
الدوله للتعاون الدولي بوزاره الخارجيه
القطريه السيده لولو والخاطر كانت اول
الواصلين الى غزه ساعه فتح معبر رفح من
الجانب المصري على راس وفد قطري في اطار
تنسيق الجهود الانسانيه المتواصله
الوزيره الخاطر حرصت على تقديم التعازي
لمدير مكتب الجزيره في غزه وائل الدحدوح
باستشهاد افراد من اسرته واسر زملاء اخرين
من شبكه الجزيره والاسره الاعلاميه في غزه
بشكل عام
عظم
الله الله ي يقول الروائي البرازيلي
المعروف باولو كويلو ان الهديه هي ان تمنح
شيئا من ذاتك لذلك لم يجد جندي اسرائيلي
في غزه هديه يقدمها لطفلته في عيدها
الثاني ميلادها ميلاد حياتها الا صوره
القتل والتدمير استخرجها من ذاته
الاجراميه وفجر بها مبنى سكنيا ل اسر
واطفال مستضعفين على امل ان تعيش طفلته
حياه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
سعيده اخيرا ما يزال ابو عبيده يتصدر
قائمه الابطال في مخيله الطفوله العربيه
تلميذ من عمان يضع اسم ابو عبيده اجابه
على سؤال في ورقه الاختبار حول الشخصيه
التي يحلم ان يكون مثلها في المستقبل اما
في عمان فقد حضر ابو عبيده شخصيا الى
الاذاعه الصباحيه باحدى المدارس ممثلا
باحد الاطفال التلاميذ يقوم مجاهدون
بعمليات الرصد والتقرب من اليات
[موسيقى]
العدو ختاما ستكبر حلا طفله فلسطين الحلوه
وستعيش ما شاء الله لها ان تعيش على ارض
ابائها
واجداد ستزرع حل الحقل ابناء يحرثون ستعلم
تلامذتها في درس الرياضيات ان الاحتلال
والحريه لا يلتقيان
حل الاطفال وتصف لهم الدواء جرعه مقاومه
كل صباح ومساء لن تقف حال على الحدود
فهويت ارضها والارض لا تحمل على المعابر
ستكبر حلا ويصغر البشع سيخطب حلا شاب لفحت
شمس يافا ويقام عرسها في قاعه مقدسيه
يحضره احبه كانوا شه ثم عادوا الى مواسم
التين والزيتون ان لوعد عظيم والقادم احلى
يا
حلا ايش بتبيعي انت حلو اها انت من وين
سان الشمال جماليه اه يعني انت نازحه ايش
نازحه نزحت من الحرب شربنا على المدارس
مدرسه ابو عربان كم اخوه عندك ايه لاثه
واختين حده اللي حده فطار وهي
انا انت ايش قدش تعملي في اليوم لو بدك
تبيعي يعني 20 15 على حاله يعني طيب والله
كويس زي يوميتي انت ويت اكثر مني احنا كنا
قاعدين من الشغل طيب ايش اسمك انت حلا اها
ايش شفتي في الحرب ايش الشي اللي خوفك
الشهداء شفتي شهداء على الارض تشعر بدني
اها والله شوون في اخبار عن بيتكم شو
بيتكم ضاير ولا راح راح
[موسيقى]
ا